[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
grand jt des territoires sur vos chaînes
locales et régionales et sur tv5 monde
voici les titres de l'actualité
couvre-feu retardé intérieur ouvert
comment s'est déroulée la troisième
étape du déconfinement dans les yvelines
les caméras de tv 78 se sont rendus
mercredi soir dans les cuisines du chef
simone zanoni la clientèle vous le
verrez et est au rendez vous en
martinique la chaîne vient à tv va nous
raconter le business des élections dans
ce journal
à dix jours du premier tour la
communication des candidats s'accélère
les coups de campagnes aussi dans cette
élection territoriale annulé l'an passé
à cause du coc vide le salon viva tech
le plus important d'europe pour les
start up et innovation du futur débute
mercredi prochain vous découvrirez avec
la provence nos confrères deux
entreprises de la région sud
participantes est impatiente évidemment
de rencontrer les potentiels clients et
les champions de la tech
après plusieurs mois son salon enfin
dans ce journal de bien belles images à
découvrir de nos confrères de corse
matin sur place celle de la
réintroduction dans le paysage de l'île
de beauté d'oiseaux rares et menacées
ils ont repris du service le soir et ce
avec plaisir et envie
les restaurateurs peuvent enfin
accueillir des clients jusqu'à 23h en
terrasse ou en salle
aversa et vous allez le voir dans les
yvelines il y avait foule pour cette
nouvelle étape du déconfinement et
notamment dans les restaurants du côté
de la ville royale
reportage dans la pizzeria césar du chef
simone zanoni d'astrid bergère la
rédaction de télé 78 la chaîne des
yvelines sur place des clients souriant
et nombreux à la pizzeria césar bike
simoné giannoni la terrasse n'a pas
désempli dans la soirée du mercredi 9
juin
cette journée marquait une nouvelle
étape dans le déconfinement il est
désormais possible de manger en
intérieur et surtout le couvre-feu était
repoussé à 23 heures
ça changeait tout bascule c'est pas que
ça nous permet de chefs de service et
pas l'essentiel
c'est surtout que les clients puissent
avoir le temps de manger tranquillement
qui sont pas pressés de partir des gens
qui arrivent à l'inter au service
nous parfois à 20h45 pour les aviser
écouter les desserts on voulait mais
emporté au pouvoir ou servir c'était
vraiment assez désagréable c'était un
petit au mercer a fait le restaurant est
idéalement situé à proximité du château
de versailles
si les touristes internationaux ne
sommes pas encore revenus les français
de tout l'hexagone se sont bien présents
a décidé d'aller à versailles pour
visiter le char de versailles donc ce
combat visited main mais on a dit on à
venu un jour auparavant pour profiter de
l'ouverture des restaurants pourraient
justement parce que c'est ce qu'on
attendait plus longtemps pour profiter
un peu des terrasses et puis si le temps
nous nous permet alors ça c'est
impeccable parce qu'à strasbourg y pleut
actuellement et ses clients n'étaient
pas retourner au restaurant depuis des
mois ce couvre-feu à 23h les a motivés
vous savez déjà au niveau des
restaurants parce qu'on peut mieux
choisir les restants les terrasses et
puis bon effectivement d'avoir le temps
c'est quand même très appréciable même
si des clients pouvaient aller en
intérieur peut on fait ce choix en
raison du temps prochaine étape du dcau
finement le 30 juin
les restaurants pour ouvrir à 100% leur
jauge en intérieur et couvre feu sera
supprimé et partout en france les
commerçants sont ravis évidemment de
retrouver davantage de liberté dans la
loi vous allez le voir de nombreux
restaurateurs qui n'étaient pas encore
ouverts faute d'espacés extérieurs ont
profité du temps d'aider confinement
pour réaliser des travaux et réaménager
leur salle et ce grâce notamment aux
aides de l'état
un reportage dans deux restaurants de la
loire d'adrien l'étrier de lisa hervé
pour la chaîne locale tl7 la télévision
de la loire ça soit un peu cosy à la
fois zen c'est clair aujourd'hui c'est
je pense que c'est plus agréable
on a gagné en surface aussi sandrine a
décidé de faire peau neuve pour sa
réouverture son restaurant qui se tient
dans le quartier de bellevue n'a plus la
même devant tueur ni le même intérieur
les aquariums ont disparu le mobilier a
été là j'aurais ça fait pratiquement
deux mois que je suis dans les travaux
je reconnais que j'ai pas compter mes
heures et
voilà c'est je suis fatigué mais c'est
une bonne fatigue les restaurateurs
avaient le choix entre une aide maximum
de dix mille euros ou une indemnisation
tous les mois de 15 à 20% du chiffre
d'affaires habituel
ce soutien du gouvernement a pu aider
certains gérants mais du côté de
sandrine ça n'a pas été le cas grec
c'est parce qu'il m'a payé mes travaux
en sortait de l'hiver j'avais de la
trésorerie qu donc ça je dirais que
quand on a rattaquer après au mois de
juin l'année dernière j'ai bouffé ma
trésorerie
alors après oui on a été des mais
giresse et ça arrivait presque un peu
tard ben ça m'a permis mois à nouveau de
réouvrir un peu plus loin à saint genest
lerpt même constat stéphane a attendu le
9 juin pour ouvrir donc nous avons fait
un petit coin un petit peu plus bar à
tapas avec des colos sa terrasse devient
tout neuf est aussi plus grande
la région est aussi venu à la rescousse
des restaurateurs des aides pour la
vente à emporter pour la numérisation et
pour les investissements étaient
possibles mais beaucoup n'ont pas
profité
il n'y avait pas spécialement d'infos là
dessus après
je veux on n'a pas demandé spécialement
des ablutions l'été les restaurateurs
seront encore accompagné par l'état mais
les aides diminueront progressivement
jusqu'en septembre
les restaurants deviendront autonomes à
la rentrée prochaine ils sont déjà
nombreux sur les routes de nos régions
le mois de juin marque le début de la
saison des camping cars
conséquence inattendue de l'épidémie du
coronavirus leurs utilisateurs sont de
plus en plus nombreux et de plus en plus
jeunes aussi la nouvelle aquitaine reste
une des destinations privilégiées des
adeptes de ce mode de vacances et de
déplacement elle est même la deuxième
région la plus visitée de france
explication de ce boom des ventes avec
baptiste monge et pour tv7 la chaîne du
groupe sud ouest
ils seront peut être les stars de l'iti
après la pandémie beaucoup se lancent
dans leurs premières vacances en camping
car
yves et nadine eux sillonnent les routes
de france depuis près de 15 ans là on
est déjà sorti un peu dans les landes et
on a vu qu'il ya de plus en plus de
monde là les airs nous puisqu'on est sur
des armes tant qu'ambassadeur et j'ai
remarqué marc il y en a de plus en plus
jeunes et qui pourrait calmer car avant
d elecam écarter les retraités et les
cils elle a beaucoup de familles
une tendance qui se confirme dans les
chiffres cette concession de sainte
eulalie a vendu 10% de véhicules en plus
cette année sur scène extérieure à
l'aide
notre coeur de marché il est vraiment
située sur le front et sur le camp
picard en profilés voilà toutes marques
confondues je vais dire mais des marques
plus accessible aux marchés où on va
démarrer dans les cinquante cinquante
cinq mille euros
voilà des prix qui ne dissuade pas les
nouveaux campings caristes sensation de
liberté retrouvée
voyage à l'intérieur du territoire
français ses atouts en temps de pandémie
bouscule le marché du camping-car des
kit d'adaptation pour le store on vend
beaucoup plus de véhicules
neuf aujourd'hui par contre on a de
moins en moins d'occasions a proposé
dans la mesure où on a toutes ses salles
de nouveaux clients qui n'ont pas déjà
d'équipements de camping-cars donc on
fait pas de reprise lent de pays basque
charentes la région a la cote auprès des
conducteurs de camping-cars 19% d'entre
7 et et prendront les routes de
nouvelles aquitaine dans le reste de
l'actualité la campagne électorale pour
les élections des 20 et 27 juin a
officiellement commencé vous le savez
une campagne rendue difficile pour les
candidats à cause de l'épidémie avec un
contexte particulier qui bénéficie
néanmoins à des entreprises meeting
voiture sonorisée affiches tracts tout
un écosystème se met en place notamment
en martinique vous allez le voir pour
convaincre les électeurs
un reportage sur place dans les
coulisses de l'économie des élections de
johan charpentier titi pour via la tv
dans cette imprimerie du lamentin les
machines tournent à plein régime
affiches tracts programme l'équipe ne
s'arrête jamais par candidat ça
représente les bulletins de vote on
imprime ses 180 mille bulletins de vote
et les circulaires ça représente 350
milles de circulaire les élections de là
ctm sont mon avis les élections les plus
importantes en termes de volume papier
ça représente à peu près 4,5 tonnes par
candidat et il ya 14 listes donc ça
donne vraiment du travail à toutes les
imprimeries d'olive autre outil
indispensable la sonorisation des
véhicules et des salles de meeting être
vu et entendu un enjeu majeur des
élections
ce professionnel à équiper une
cinquantaine de voitures et concernant
les meetings un soin particulier a été
porté au numérique lors des meetings par
rapport aux problèmes sanitaires
ils peuvent pas recevoir autant de monde
donc il s'agit de faire en sorte que sur
ceux qui sont à distance
ce les réseaux sociaux que les meetings
puissent être les gens puissent plus
être suivi enfin il y a les loueurs de
voitures citadines berlines minivan tout
dépend des besoins des différentes
listes mais contrairement aux deux
autres secteurs les élections
territoriales ne représente pas pour eux
la période la plus lucrative de l'année
pour nous clairement c'est une activité
je veux dire dans la vie de la cité quoi
c'est une activité normale
on sera aussi traditionnellement lors
des élections des véhicules font sont
loués à des femmes campagne sont
équipées de ce nom et et parcours en jeu
d'après guerre la matinée si la campagne
profitent à tout un écosystème
rappelons que les tarifs pratiqués
doivent être transparents et égaux pour
tous les candidats et comptes de
campagne seront passés au peigne fin
après les élections améliorer les
prévisions météo et éviter ainsi les
catastrophes dues aux intempéries
l'enjeu est de taille pour de nombreux
professionnels et pour l'avenir bien sûr
et pour y parvenir météo france est en
train de tester un nouveau super
calculateur à toulouse l'outil
impressionnant par sa taille comme vous
pouvez le voir sur ces images de nos
confrères de la dépêche
on tient la puissance de 50 mille
ordinateurs classiques
il permettra bien sûr d'affiner les
prévisions météo sur tout le territoire
écoutez à ce propos alain bureau il est
responsable de ce projet au micro de
clément gars si l'idée c'est d'amener
d'améliorer la chronologie et
l'anticipation surtout des événements
des événements c'est vers les plus
intenses des phénomènes de neige vers
qu'il a maintenant que cette machine est
en opérationnel et qu'elle est à la
disposition des chercheurs
les équipes sont en plein travail pour
préparer les nouvelles générations de
modèles de prévision qui vont mettre
d'être mise en opérationnel donc début
2022 ce sont 7000 tonnes de ballast 5000
travers ses 7000 mètres de rails voilà
ce qu'est le bilan des matériaux
nécessaires à la réfection de la voie du
mythique et historique mont blanc
express entre saint gervais et chameaux
knicks jusqu'à 80 personnes ont
travaillé sur ce chantier pour le moins
impressionnant entamées en 2019 les
travaux viennent tout juste de se
terminer
une bonne nouvelle pour les habitants et
le tissu économique local
le point sur ses finitions avec victoria
lopez de 8 mont blanc sur place elle
relie saint gervais à vallorcine puis
martigny en suisse
cette ligne ferroviaire frontalière de
montagne est particulière l'écartement
des rails et d'un mètre contre un peu
moins d'un mètre cinquante sur le reste
du réseau français depuis le 10 mai la
circulation des trains entre saint
gervais et chamonix est interrompue rien
d'anormal en cette période de
maintenance annuelle à laquelle s'ajoute
cette année la dernière étape
d'importants travaux de régénération de
la voix entamées en 2019 en arène
renouvelé en 2010 9 environ 3 km de
voies ferrées à proximité de saint
gervais et en 2020 on à renouveler
environ 4 km de voies ferrées
on était sur des hommes qui avaient
encore des composants qui avait près
d'un siècle qui datait de la création de
la ligne
donc il était important de renouveler
ces zones de voix pour maintenir les
performances de la ligne pour les pour
les 40 prochaines années environ les
trois composantes de la voix le ballast
pour son maintien
les traverses et les rails ont ainsi été
renouvelés
tout comme le troisième rail
d'alimentation électrique un système
spécifique à cette voie l'électricité
étant sur la plupart du réseau français
a porté par des caténaires associés à
ces travaux voyage d'autres travaux qui
ont été réalisés avec des sécurisations
de paroi rocheuse la mise en place de
grillage plaque est ancrée
pour sécuriser de les parois rocheuses
depuis 2010 9,7 km de voies sur les 36
de la ligne côté français ont été
refaits entre le fayet et les houches
au total 24 km ont été rénovés depuis
2008 et le début du grand plan de
modernisation du mont blanc express
la circulation des trains reprendra
normalement dès le 5 juin
d'ici là des bus de substitution sont
toujours proposés l'économie dans nos
régions à présent avec le retour après
une pause forcée du premier salon
européen dédié aux innovations et aux
start up villatech dès mercredi prochain
pour quatre jours l'ensemble des acteurs
et décideurs de la tec ont rendez vous à
paris au parc des expositions est
l'évènement sera également à suivre sur
internet du fait des règles sanitaires
bien sûr parmi les chefs d'entreprise
présents on notera notamment la venue de
mark zuckerberg le fondateur de facebook
ou encore de tim cook le directeur
général d'apple
mais au-delà de ces géants le salon qui
va tech est aussi l'occasion pour les
jeunes entreprises françaises de se
faire connaître et de conquérir de
nouveaux marchés
sur ce sujet on écoute le directeur
général de x rapide fabricant de masques
intelligent qui est basée à
aix-en-provence propos récoltés par nos
confrères de la provence sur place j'ai
demandé à mes ingénieurs en début de koh
vide de me fabriquer un masque que je
puisse porter tout le temps qui me
permet de respirer comme si je n'avais
pas de masque
c'est à dire pas de but et pas de
chaleur à l'intérieur pas de difficultés
à faire passer l'air à l'intérieur ou à
l'extérieur et pour 5 le masque analyse
en permanence que vous faites et vous
aide
inspiré et a expiré le moment venu si
vous êtes en train d'inspirer il ya des
moteurs d'inspiration qui vont forcer
l'air à l'intérieur de temps avant
d'expirer ça va sortir de l'intérieur on
espère sortir d'ici à la fin de l'été
les premières versions sans doute pour
la médecine autres entreprises
installées dans la région paca et qui
participera au salon à partir de
mercredi
wise intégration cette start-up
révolutionne notamment l' usage de la
prise électrique thierry boucher et son
directeur général écoutons le alors ça
c'est le flat cube on l'a appelée c'est
donc un chargeur très compact qui tient
dans la poche et qui charge l'ensemble
de vos équipements électroniques donc
avec un seul point
chargeurs on peut charger l'ordinateur
le smartphone rapidement et même le vélo
électrique
il va tech 2021 pour nous c'est un salon
très important parce que c'est d'abord
un salon consumer redon qui s'adresse au
grand public avec des applications grand
public et donc pour nous c'est la
promotion de nos produits c'est la
possibilité de rencontrer donc à la fois
des investisseurs et surtout des
potentiels clients des prospects et puis
aussi pourquoi pas des futurs
collaborateurs
et comme toutes les semaines l'économie
c'est aussi avec vous bonjour michel
picaud vous nous parler aujourd'hui du
made in france et plus précisément de la
certification origine france garantie
bonjour cyril bonjour à tous je voulais
vous parler aujourd'hui d'un homme de
conviction et d'une marque de costumes
médine l'image l'homme de conviction
s'appelle gilles attaf filer le nouveau
président de la certification origine
france garantie
attention ce n'est pas une nouvelle
étiquette ou un label mais bien d'une
certification est ici l'origine france
est réellement garantie mais gilles
attaf fait aussi un créateur de mode
on lui doit la marque de costumes smig
l'air en sommeil actuellement en france
puisque sa confection est parti au
portugal
alors j la taf a décidé de relancer de
nouveaux costumes et une nouvelle marque
magnifiant le chic à la française qui
s'appelle belleville manufacture et tous
ces costumes sont confectionnés à
limoges produire en france c'est dans
l'adn de gila taf pour qui le acheter
français a fait un grand bond ces
derniers mois les consommateurs ont bien
ancrés dans leur esprit l'importance dû
acheter made in france et demain avec
les nouvelles technologies des
industries plus petit et souvent pilotés
technologiquement grâce à la 5g
permettront de développer des usines de
production dans tous nos territoires
la technologie et la robotisation sont
autant de chance pour produire à prix
raisonnable et créer des emplois
qualifiés et formés dans nos territoires
nous sommes à un tournant du made in
france me confié gilles attaf d'où son
initiative
les forces françaises de l'industrie
dont l'objectif est de fédérer des pme
industrielles en partant du constat que
nous sommes bons dans ce pays pour faire
émerger de belles start-up la mode le
luxe la gastronomie l'agroalimentaire le
design le tourisme et beaucoup d'autres
autant de secteurs sur lesquels les
français
et la production française peuvent être
perçu comme un avantage concurrentiel à
l'international voilà merci michel
picaud on vous retrouve dans une
prochaine édition du grand jt des
territoires pour nous parler de
l'économie de nos régions mais nous
restons à limoges pour évoquer à présent
le rôle social de l'art en avant
première du festival ça mijote c'est son
nom des artistes ont accompagné des
adultes en situation de handicap dans
leur réalisation d'une fresque géante
celle ci sera ensuite exposée dans les
rues de la ville à partir du 3 juillet
alain drouho pour la rédaction de cet
animal sur place regardez quand la
culture est accessible à tous dans la
rue elle peut être également produite
par touche ça mijote est porté par la
ville de limoges l'association limousine
art la fondation delta plus et ses
résidents et un collectif d'artistes un
tout petit peu en avance sur le festival
de street art de limoges qui démarre le
3 juillet alors maintenant
positionnement en tant que personnes qui
les fait du street art régulièrement
c'est que quand même c'est une des
seules manières de poires en live l'art
accessible à tous sans aucune contrainte
qu'elle soit financière ou autre
donc c'est ça que je trouve hyper
intéressant et aussi ça quand on
travaille dans la rue en tant qu'artiste
ça génère énormément d'interaction qui
sont très fortes pas très intéressante
pour ces adultes en situation de
handicap psychique les bénéfices sont
importants chez tout d'abord le plaisir
de créer c'est important d'avoir aussi
cette ouverture vers l'extérieur
donc c'est tout le sens en tête de
l'activité
ça permet aux résidents aussi d'avoir
une réelle utilité sociale une ouverture
sur la cité donc ça c'est vraiment très
important
ce qu'il faut être gourmand pour peindre
un gâteau le tour la fresque de 12
mètres de long sur 1 visible dès
l'ouverture du festival de street art
festival de limoges
en corse maintenant défi sportif qui
rime avec solidarité et écologie
deux amis vient de parcourir 700 km sur
des vélos écolo et électriques
comme vous pouvez le voir sur ces images
devient telle est pas aisé une aventure
à travers liste de beauté puisque celle
ci visait à sensibiliser les habitants à
la maladie de la jeune lou six ans la
petite fille est atteinte du syndrome
rare de rett qui se traduit par un
polype handicap grâce aux fonds récoltés
en ligne notamment les deux aventuriers
aide de la famille de loups à financer
soins et matérielles mais des idées de
les aider donc à la fois dans leur
quotidien pour essayer de leur faire va
les faire sortir de cette difficulté qui
doivent gérer au quotidien mais
également d'un point de vue financier
puisqu'il y avait beaucoup de choses qui
sont pas remboursés ni par la sécurité
sociale ni parlent les mutuelles privées
comme le siège qu'on lui a offert un
siège à 1300 euros pour qu'elle n'ait
pas de scoliose on est maintenant sur
une deuxième étape on essaie d'atteindre
les 3000 euros pour lui offrir de
l'équité rapide et on a assez récemment
dépasser ce plafond donc maintenant
passer à la troisième stade pour faire
des soins
une semaine en famille en pologne
puisque les soins sont un petit peu
moins cher là-bas une autre belle action
en corse la réintroduction sur l'île de
beauté de 2 pouces un gypaète barbu
je vous en parlais dans les titres
l'espèce est menacée pour de multiples
raisons
et c'est donc pour favoriser son
développement que ces deux vautours ont
été relâchés dans le parc naturel
régional local leurs comportements
seront surveillés à la loupe pendant des
mois par des spécialistes
écoutez à ce sujet l'un des membres du
parc interrogés par la rédaction de
corse matin sur place il n'y a pas de
facteur prédominant mais il est vrai que
bon depuis les années 50 il ya une
baisse du pastoralisme encore surtout de
l'est steve donc le gypaète étant est
inscrit dimanche charognards se nourrit
des carcasses qui trouve en montagne la
ressource sauvage typiquement de
mouflons est bon aujourd'hui on en prend
depuis depuis depuis assez longtemps en
nombre insuffisant donc c'est un une
espèce qui est très très lié aux
ressources domestiques en bretagne cette
fois ci les enjeux pour la biodiversité
sont évidemment différent dans les eaux
de la pointe de la varde nous allons
nous rendre maintenant à saint malo se
trouve un herbier marin très précieux
pour les espèces vivantes de mouillage
écologique viennent d'être installés
pour préserver cette prairie des mères
ils doivent aussi faciliter la
cohabitation avec la pêche à pied et de
plaisance détails et explications de
claudia kara tories pour tvr arènes
regarder
imaginez une prairie immergée de
zostères marine des plantes qui servent
de nursery aux poissons mollusques et
crustacés
vous êtes au coeur d'un herbier marin
celui de la pointe de la varde à saint
malo est particulièrement surveillé car
il cohabite avec la pêche à pied et la
plaisance de mouillage innovant viennent
d'être installés il ya un constat qui
est fait à l'échelle de la bretagne mais
aussi à l'échelle de la méditerranée sur
d'autres herbiers marins comme quoi le
l'ancrage a un impact négatif sur ses
sur ces rda et les mouillages également
on se retrouve on a des images aériennes
qui permettent d'attester ça de voir ce
qu'on appelle un herbier qui se
fragmente qui ce mythe
parce que au droit des mouillages on va
avoir des zones de clairière qui vont
apparaître qu'ils sont liés au fait que
la chaîne va ragués c'est-à-dire racler
le fond et détruire l'arbre
l'association des pêcheurs plaisanciers
de roter 9 utilisatrices des lieux à
aider il y a quelques jours à
l'installation de ces deux mouillage
écologique financé par saint malo ceux
ci comportent une ligne textile pour
glisser et non frotter sur la flore
marines et leurs chaînes ne touche pas
le fond c'est une très bonne nouvelle
puisque de toute façon nous continuerons
à améliorer les mouillages les
mouillages qui nous a amené son un tout
petit peu plus sophistiqué que les
nôtres puisque la seule différence est
que le boot de nylon qu'on nous a amenés
sur ces nouveaux voyages et en des temps
comment entouré d'une gaine plastique
plusieurs partenaires prennent part à ce
projet est coordonné par l'association
planète mer on est sur un site pilote et
est on expérimente on va bilan t au bout
de trois ans si le bilan est positif
eh ben on sait que ça pourra servir sur
d'autres sites qui ont les mêmes
problématiques
le programme de recherche de l'herbier
marins de la varde va durer trois ans
les conclusions de cette expérimentation
seront remontés à l'office français de
la biodiversité
voilà après la bretagne on se rend à
monaco pour découvrir un véhicule tout à
fait étonnant qui s'appelle on parque
tic à celui ci n'est pas destinée à la
route mais à l'exploration des pôles ce
véhicule produit par le constructeur
monégasque venturi servir dans quelques
mois à la communauté scientifique
son originalité il est 100% électrique
et donc moins polluants pour
l'environnement observer le projet
nouvelle génération était dévoilée il ya
quelques jours au prince albert de
monaco et sandrine et orazio
gaijin aux journalistes pour monaco info
étaient sur place
regardez après son retour de
l'antarctique en 2009 le souverain fait
part d'un constat au président de 28 les
stations de recherche scientifique ne
dispose pas de véhicules non polluants
la fondation prince albert ii charges
allant le constructeur monégasque de
trouver une solution solution trouvée
elle porte le nom d'antarctique à trois
versions du véhicule sont conçus la
dernière née a été dévoilée dans les
locaux de 28
c'est vrai que ça a été un très long
processus parce qu'il a fallu assure
tester des choses que tout le monde
pense est très difficile voire même
impossible et du double du premier
prototype que j'ai pu essayer et qu'on a
pu essayer non seulement ici dans la
région mais au canada
on a rendu compte à notre patron c'était
possible de faire aujourd'hui sert en
antarctique évoluer ce véhicule c'est
bien le faire peut-être un jour arriver
à toucher le pôle sud
ce sera très très bien la nouvelle
version du modèle antartica premier
véhicule d'exploration polaire zéro
émission sera rattaché dans quelques
mois en décembre 2021 à la base
scientifique princesse elisabeth en
antarctique antartica et dotés de
solutions technologiques qui concerne
l'isolation thermique la batterie et la
structure du châssis on est reparti
d'une feuille blanche
mais en se basant sur nos connaissances
donc c'est une maturité du produit
véhicules antartica on a rajouté des
panneaux solaires pour voir utiliser
l'énergie solaire pour utiliser un
système de réchauffage de l'habitacle
mais également aux besoins recharger un
petit peu les batteries à noter pour
finir que le choix de la date de
présentation d'une nouvelle antarctique
n est pas le fruit du hasard
le véhicule éco responsable a été
dévoilée en ce début du mois de juin
quelques jours à peine avant la journée
mondiale de l'environnement
voilà c'est la fin de ce long j'étais
des territoires on se retrouve très
bientôt sur la chaîne locale ces
régionales ou sur tv5 monde
bonne journée à très bientôt fois
[Musique]